[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا في كل مكان اهلا بكم جميعا الى
حلقه جديده من برنامج من واشنطن كل الطرق
تؤدي الى الشرق الاوسط في الحسابات
الامريكيه احدث نموذج لذلك ملف ايران
واوكرانيا
هناك تهديد محدد يثير المخاوف في واشنط
وعلى مستوى العالم يتعلق بنقل المسيرات
الانتحاريه الايرانيه الى روسيا ونحن
نلاحظ ان الروس يستخدمون المسيرات
الهجوميه الايرانيه لاستهداف البنيه
التحتيه المدنيه الاوكرانيه وقطاع الطاقه
وازهاق ارواح المدنيين ما يقلقنا هو ان
ايران وقادتها العسكريين سوف يستخلصون
دروسا مهمه ستزيد من القدرات الفتاكه لهذه
الاسلحه وتطورها وهذه الاسلحه سيعاد
استخدامها وستكون فعاله اكثر وتزيد
التهديدات لشعوب واراضي شركاء الولايات
المتحده في الشرق الاوسط كما راينا تقارير
صحفيه حول التفكير باقامه منشات ايرانيه
لانتاج عداد داخل روسيا اضافه الى تقارير
حول مبيعات طائرات حربيه روسيه لايران وكل
هذه الامور تزيد من التهديدات العسكريه في
المنطقه
دانا سترول نائبه مساعد وزير الدفاع
الامريكي للشرق الاوسط كانت تتحدث عن
المسيرات الايرانيه كما قالت في لقاء خاص
مع الجزيره قبيله سفرها في زياره رسميه
الى المنطقه ضمن راسه وزير الدفاع نريد
اوستن اداره الرئيس بايدن التي كانت في
بدايتها متحمسه لاحياء الاتفاق النووي مع
ايران بدات في الاونه الاخيره تقول ان
المفاوضات مع الايرانيين في هذا الشان لم
تعد ضمن اجندتها الراهنه
فهل حل اهتمامها العسكري محل اهتمامها
بالحل السلمي مع الايرانيين
سنسمع رد الاداره على هذا السؤال بعد قليل
ولكن بعد ان نسمع ما قاله مايك بومبيو
وزير خارجيه الرئيس السابق دون درامب صاحب
قرار اغتيال الجنرال الايراني قاسم
سليماني في الثالث من مثل هذا الشهر عام
2020 نسمع لما قاله عن عمليه الاغتيال
حقيقه ان الايرانيين غاضبون بما يكفي من
مايك بومبيو تعني ان سياستنا كانت صائبه
واننا فهمنا تهديد الذي يواجه الولايات
المتحده ودافعنا عنها بلا هواده اسميت
كتابي لا تنازل عن قيد اممله لم نتنحى ولو
قيد اموله في هذه الامور المهمه
كان يتحدث في تصريح حصلت عليه الجزيره
دونالد ترامب كان قد سحب بلاده من الاتفاق
النووي مع ايران فهل ستحيي اداره بايدن
جهودها لاحياء الاتفاق ام انما يصفه
الامريكيون وحلفائهم الاوروبيون بتعاون
ايران العسكري المتزايد كما يقولون مع
روسيا في حربها على اوكرانيا سيجعل من ذلك
هدفا بعيدا المنال او حتى غير مرغوب فيه
امريكيا
مجله
نشرت هذا الاسبوع مقاله من ضمن ما جاء
فيها مثلا اثار التحالف المتنامي قلقا
داخل حلفيه الناتو خاصه بين القوى
الاوروبيه التي ساعد الى الحفاظ على
الحوار مستمرا مع ايران لاحياء المفاوضات
الدبلوماسيه بشان برنامجها للتسلح النووي
التحالف المتزايد تقول بين ايران وروسيا
وفي الوقت الذي يزور فيه وزير الدفاع عن
منطقه عقب المناورات العسكريه الضخمه التي
جمعت القوات الامريكيه والاسرائيليه نهايه
الشهر الماضي وكذلك التهديدات الاسرائيليه
بضرب المنشات النوويه الايرانيه جاء ايضا
في مقاله
قال مسؤول امريكي انه اذا زودت روسيا
ايران بانظمه دفاع جوي متطوره مثل نظم
صواريخ اس 300 او اس 400 فان ذلك سيساعد
طهران على حمايه منشاتها النوويه بشكل
افضل من ضربات اسرائيليه محتمله
اذا تشابكت خيوط الملفين الايراني
والاوكراني في واشنطن فهل سيكون بامكاني
اداره الرئيس جو بايدن فصل الملفين في
المستقبل اذا اقترضت المصلحه الامريكيه
ذلك هذه القضيه كنت قد اثرتها بالاضافه
طبعا لقضايا اخرى في لقاء مع سامويل و
بيرج الناطق الاقليمي باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه
مرحبا بك في برنامج من واشنطن بالنسبه
للملف النووي الايراني يعني اين يقع
التفاوض على سلم اولويات اداره الرئيس
بايدن في هذا الوقت
اذا شكرا على الاستضافه يا استاذ عبد
الرحيم وكما سمعنا من الوزير بلينكن
والتكرار في هذا الوقت
المفاوضات حول البرنامج النووي الايراني
ليس في راس الاجاند هذا نحن ليس لدينا قلق
شديد بالنسبه على البرنامج النووي لايراني
لان مازال نحن نرى ان هذا البرنامج النووي
الايراني بدون القيود التي كان لدينا حول
البرمجه من قبل هي فعلا خطيره جدا وتمثل
خطوره للمنطقه بشكل عام وللعالم ولذلك
لدينا علميه للعوده الى الاتفاق النووي
كما كان لدينا في 2015 ولكن بكل اسف
الاداره السابقه سحبه الولايات المتحده من
هذه الاتفاق هذا الاتفاق ونحن نريد
النعارض ورئيس بايدن هو كان واضح جدا من
اليوم الاول من اداراته قال ان نحن مستعده
الولايات المتحده مستعده لاتخاذ كل
الاجراءات اللازمه للعوده الى الاتفاق
النووي اذا الى
تقوم بالامتثال كامل ولكن كان نص موجود من
الاتحاد الاوروبي في شهر سبتمبر في شهر
تسعه ولكن في نهايه المطاف الحكومه
الايرانيه رفضت رفضت للعوده الى الاتفاق
النووي والان لازم نقول انها تركيزنا على
الاولويات الاخرى ومنها الدعم الشعب
الايراني في ويشعل القمر دودهم من
المتظاهرات وعيدا القلق لدينا
الخطوات لازم لازم ناخذها لمنع ايران من
الشراكه ما الروسيه بنسبه هذه الاسلحه
التي تقدمها ايران للروسيه لاستعمالها
الروسيه
اذا نعم نحن ما زال لدينا هذا القلب
الشديد حول البرنامج النووي الايراني ولكن
بالنسبه المفاوضات هي ليس في الراس
اولوياتنا بالنسبه للزياره التي قام بها
السيد جروسي من وكاله الطاقه الذريه يعني
الى اي مدى نفخت انجاز التعبير هذه
الزياره الروح مجددا في عمليه التفاوض
بالنظر الى الانتقادات الحاده التي
سمعناها من رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو لهذه الزياره وللتصريحات
التي صدرت عن السيد جروس
نعم اذا بالشكل عام بشكل عام يا استاذ عبد
الرحيم نحن نرحب اي تنسيق بين الوكاله
الدوليه الطاقه الذريه
والحكومه الايرانيه نحن نراهب اي زيارات
من مدير عام لان نحن نرى ان اي زيارات من
المدير العامج الروسي واي تنسيق ستؤدي الى
شفافيه اكثر بنسبه التفاصيل وبنسبه الوعي
لازم نكون لدينا حول البرنامج النووي
الايراني ولذلك نحن نرحب بعد التنسيق نحن
نرهب هذه الزيارات ولكن السؤال ما منى
وامام المجتمع الدولي هل فعلا الحكومه
الايرانيه ستقوم بتنفيذ وعودها سمانه بكل
اسف سمعنا مرارا وتكرارا بعد هذه الزيارات
ومثلها في الماضي وعود من ايران حول
الامتثاله كامل والاجراءات التي ستخذها
ولشفافيه ولكن فشلت مرار متكرار ان
الحكومه الايرانيه بنسبه هذه الوعود
وبالنسبه التزاماتنا اذا من اللازم الان
نرى التطبيق نرى التفاصيل نرى المعلومات
الشفافيه وبشفافه من الحكومه الايرانيه
بالنسبه لعمليه التفاوض السيد
يعني وزير الدفاع الامريكي يوجد في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط حاليا
لتنسيق المواقف بين الحلفاء كما قيل سبقت
ذلك مناورات عسكريه بين الولايات المتحده
واسرائيل يعني هل تشير هذه التطورات الى
ان الخيار العسكري قد اصبح ابرز على رادار
اداره بايدن فيما يتعلق بالملف النووي
الايراني
لا نريد ان نقول ابرز الخيارات لان من
بدايه هذه الاداره سمعنا من رئيس بايدن هو
قال انه
لن يسمع ايران ان امتلك النوويه ابدا اذا
لدينا كل الخيارات امامنا لدينا الولايات
المتحده مستعده للكل من السيناريوهات مع
العوده الى الاتفاق النووي او بدونها
ولذلك من اللازم ان نكون بالتنسيق
ومناقشات ومنورات مع حلفائنا في المنطقه
منها اسرائيل ومنها دوله اخرى ولكن في
نهايه المطاف هذه الاداره ترى ان الحل
الدبلوماسي الحلل المفضل هناك الحال كما
تعرف
الايرانيون يقولون ان طهران ليست هي
العائق للمفاوضات مع الجانب الامريكي
يقولون بالعكس الجانب الامريكي هو الذي لا
يبدي استعداد حقيقي للتفاوض وانت اشرت في
وقت سابق الى مساله اوكرانيا انتم ت تهمون
الايرانيين بالتحالف او التعاون العسكري
الان مع الروس في اوكرانيا يعني هل يسبب
هذا الاتهام اي حرج بالنسبه لاداره بايدن
في موضوع التفاوض يعني هل لا تزال الاداره
فعلا تريد ان تتفاوض مع الايرانيين وهي
تتهمهم بانها تتهم طهران بانها تتعاون مع
الروس في اوكرانيا في حرب اوكرانيا
سؤال مهم يا استاذ عبد الرحيم لان كما
راينا في المره الاولى عندما وصلنا الى
الاتفاق النووي ما ايران في 2015 لدينا من
الجانب الامريكي ليس من الممكن ان نتكلم
من جانب الايراني او من وجهه نظر عيد
الاخرى ولكن من جانبنا الامكانيه لنركز
على اكثر من جانب لدينا الامكانيه للجلوس
على الطاوله مع ايران مع اي دوله لدينا
الخصومه او دوله متنافسه لدينا الامكانيه
للجلوس ووصول الى اتفاق معهم
على جانب او على موضوع بدون نقوم بتخليط
مع كل المواضيع الاخرى وعندما وصلنا الى
الاتفاق النووي حول البرنامج النووي
الايراني في المره الاولى في 2015 بالرغم
من الانجازات من
المفاوضات
ووصول الى الاتفاق
كل هذه التحديات الاخرى من ايران منها
تمويل الارهاب
وتدخل في الشؤون الداخليه في المنطقه والى
اخره اذا في النص النص شيء الان لدينا
الامكانيه لنقول ان نحن مستعده مستعده
العوده الى مفاوضات العوده للاتفاقناوي
ولكن في نفس الوقت لدينا هذه المخوف
الاخرى القلق الاخر بالنسبه مثلا الدعم
الايراني
للروس بالنسبه احديه لحرب الوحشيه من رئيس
بوتين على شعب الاوكراني ولدينا نفس القلق
بالنسبه قمع من النظام الايراني ضد شعبه
خاصه الفتيات والنساء ولدينا نصل قلق
تمويل الارهاب من النظام الايراني
وتدخل في شؤون داخليه في
الدول المجاوره
اعتقال او او اعتقال تعسفي بالم
الاجانب داخل ايران اذا لدينا كل هذه
القلق ولكن لدينا الامكانيه لنركز على
اكثر من جانب
العطفا عليه هو نهايه السامه
عطفا على ما تفضلت به قبل قليل يعني اذا
كان الروس يتعاونون الان عفوا اذا كان
الايرانيون يتعاونون مع الروس عسكريا في
اوكرانيا كما تتهمونهم انتم بذلك واذا
كانت روسيا
العمود مهم في مجموعه الخمسه زائد واحد في
الملف النووي الايراني يعني ما هي اهميه
هذه المجموعه الان خمسه زائد واحد
وبالتالي ما هي حظوظ التوصل الى اتفاق في
الملف النوويه الايراني
متحده لدينا علاقات قويه مع بعض الدول في
المجموعه خمسه زائد واحد منها فرنسا
والمملكه المتحده والمانيا ولدينا علاقات
اخرى وعلاقات مختلفه مع بعض البلدان مثل
الصين والروسيه ولكن هذا لا يعني ان ليس
من الممكن ان نحن كدول دول كبيره دول مهمه
انجلوس الى الاتفاق النووي او العوده الى
الاتفاق النووي كما راينا مثلا في 2015
ماذا وقعت في 2014 الغزو الاول من روسيا
على القرن وكان لدينا تحديات كبيره في
الوقت بين الولايات المتحده
والروسيه ولكن بالرغم من ذلك كان لدينا
الامكانيه للوصول الى الاتفاق النووي في
2015 اذا نحن نرى ان لدينا نص الامكانيه
اليوم لماذا لان ليس في مصلحه الروسيه او
الصين او اي دوله اخرى ان ترى الاسلحه
النوويه في ايران في الدوله مثل ايران اذا
لدينا مساله مشتركه بالرغم من كل
الاختلافات والصرعات لدينا بالنسبه بعض
الملفات مثل اوكرانيا لدينا الامكانيه
لنرى المساله المشتركه حول بعضيه مثل
الاتفاق النووي وايران
شكرا جزيلا
شكرا
كان ذلك سامو الوربرغ الناطق الاقليمي
باسمي وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ارحب الان
بمراسل الجزيره في ايران نور الدين الدغير
نور الدين مرحبا بك في برنامج من واشنطن
ما الذي يعوق التوصل الى اتفاق مع اداره
بايدن في الملف النووي الايراني من وجهه
نظر ايران
هناك مجموعه من الاشكالات التي ربما قد
تعوق التوصل الى الاتفاق بالنسبه
للايرانيين هناك مساله ترتبط بالجانب
النفسي
للايرانيين من خلال تجربتهم التاريخيه مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ومع الغرب في
مساله المفاوضات نعلم على ان هناك اتفاق
قبل اتفاق 2015 وهو اتفاق سعد 2003 واتفاق
باريس 2004 لكن رغم ذلك خرجت منه الدول
الاوروبيه الثلاث تحت ضغط الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه يتكرر نفس الامر مع
الاتفاق النووي اذا عمليا ايران تنظر بنوع
من الريبه لاي اتفاق ربما قد توقعه مع
الغض مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اذا
لم تكن هناك ضمانات حقيقيه تؤدي الى
استمرار هذا الاتفاق اذا هذا هو الجانب
النفسي الذي تتحرك عليه طهران وتريد ان
تتخلص منه من خلال الحصول على شيء يؤكد
على ان الاطراف الاخرى تريد البقاء في
الاتفاق النووي هناك مسائل ترتبط بالجانب
السياسي والجانب التقني للاتفاق هنا يتحدث
الايرانيون بكل صراحه يقول على انهم نفذوا
كل التزاماتهم منذ التحاقهم بالاتفاق
وتنفيذهم بالاتفاق لكن هناك عقيل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه التي انسحبت منها
الاتفاق تقول ترى انها ارادت البقاء في
الاتفاق واستمرت عليه لمده سنه كامله لكن
دون ان تنجح الدول الاوروبيه الثلاث في
دفع واشنطن للتراجع عن ذلك هناك نقطه
اساسيه وهي مساله العقوبات التي اعيدت
فرضها اعيد فرضها من جديد على طهران اذا
هناك نقاط اساسيه ترتبط بالجانب الاوروبي
وبالجانب الامريكي خاصه بمساله العقوبات
خاصه بالمطالب الخارجه عن نطاق الملف انه
كما يقول هنا وهي مساله الصواريخ مساله
الاقليميه وكذلك حقوق الانسان والتي يرى
الايرانيون انها احدى الملفات التي يريد
من خلالها الضغط على الطهران
يعني بالنسبه لطهران هل ترى طهران في حرب
اوكرانيا فرصه لتعزيز موقعها مع روسيا
سواء في عمليه التفاوض في الملف النووي
الايراني او في حال حصلت مواجهه او ضربه
عسكريه اسرائيليه للمنشات في ايران
عبد الرحيم هنا يجب ان نقف عند رؤيه
الايرانيين لعلاقتهم الدوليه بكل تاكيد
الكل يعلم على ان العلاقات الايرانيه
الروسيه هي علاقات قويه مقارنه مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بدل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه على الاقل تصنف هنا على
مستوى الشعارات في طهران بانها الشيطان
الاكبر الاكبر او عدو طهران لذلك فهي
علاقتها بروسيا قويه لكن يتحدث
في سله العلاقات الروسيه فقط بل يريدون
التنوع هذه الحلقات لكن بكل تاكيد الازمه
الحاصله الان ما بين ما بين موسكو وما بين
واشنطن بكل تاكيد ان تستفيد منها على
مجموعه من المستويات اول وجود عقوبات على
روسيا ووجود عقوبات على طهران هذا سيسهل
لايران على الاقل فتح باب باتجاه روسيا
على المستوى التجاره الدوليه هناك نقطه
اساسيه كذلك يمكن القول بان ايران تحاول
ان تستفيد منها من العلاقه المتوتره ما
بين واشنطن وما بين موسكو وهي انخراط
طهران على المستوى الاقتصادي على المستوى
التجاري فيما يعرف بمجموعه الاوراسيا
وكذلك الحضور القوي في منظمه شنغهاي هذا
كله ربما نتاج لهذه العلاقه المستجده
الناجمه عن التوتر ما بين واشنطن وموسكو
لكن اذا ما اردنا ان نتحدث هل يمكن ان
تستغل هذه العلاقه في مساله المفاوضات
النوويه ربما المساله ترتبط بطبيعه ما
يمكن التفاوض عليه والى اي حد يمكن ان
تحقق العلاقه مع موسكو ما تريده طهران من
مطالب وخاصه رفع العقوبات وخاصه اما
المستوى العسكري
حسب ما يقول المسؤولون العسكريين هنا على
ان الاستراتيجيه العسكريه هنا هي
استراتيجيه ايرانيه لا تبني اسسها
ومفاعلها على علاقتها مع الدول باعتبار
انها هي السياسه دفاعيه تريد منها ان
تتجاوز بها اي مخاطر ربما خاصه مع اسرائيل
وخاصه ان الايرانيون يضعون نصب اعينهم
المساله السوريه وكيف ان موسكو ربما لم
تتفاعل بشكل كبير مع ايران ضد الهجمات
الاسرائيليه على المواقع التي تطال ايران
او المجموعات التابعه لها نهايه نور الدين
يعني طبعا الاتهامات الامريكيه للايرانيين
بانهم يتعاونون مع الروس في الحرب
الاوكرانيه معروفه انما ما مدى ضلوع ايران
في الجهد الحربي الروسي في اوكرانيا حسب
طهران
هنا تصريح جميع وبمواقف جميع المسؤولين
الايرانيين من وزاره الدفاع الى هيئه
اركان الى وزاره الخارجيه الى الرئاسه
الكلهم كلهم ينسون ان تكونوا ان يكون هناك
اي دعم عسكري ايراني لروسيا في مواجهه
اوكرانيا حتى مساله المسيرات التي لدى
موسكو هنا كان وزير الخارجيه ايرانيه حسين
امير عبد الله واضحا في هذه المساله قال
بان هذه المسيرات سلمت الى موسكو قبل
الحرب وقال بانه اذا ما ثبت ان موسكو
استعملته في الحرب فهنا قد يكون هناك
تعامل جديد لايران مع موسكو بل ابعد من
ذلك يتحدث ايرانيون على انهم فتحوا باب
الحوار مع اوكرانيا وكانت احدى هذه النقاط
هو الحوار الايراني الاوكراني الذي
احتضرته عمان في احدى جولاته لكن يقول
ايرانيين الايرانيون بان الاوكرانيين لم
يقدموا اي دلائل لكن رغم ذلك لا ينفي
الايرانيين انهم لديهم علاقات عسكريه مع
روسيا باعتبار الصفقات المتبادله ما بين
طهران وموسكو في قضيه بيع وشراء الاسلحه
نور الدين شكرا جزيلا كان ذلك مراسل
للجزيره في طهران نور الدين الدغير ارحب
الان بكل من السفير جون هيربس سفير
الولايات المتحده السابق في اوكرانيا
ومدير مركز اوراسيا في المجلس الاطلسي في
واشنطن حاليا كما ارحب من موسكو بالمحلل
السياسي
مرحبا بك في برنامج من واشنطن بدايه كيف
تنظر انت الى ترابط المساله الايرانيه
والمساله الاوكرانيه في الحسابات
الامريكيه حسابات اداره الرئيس بايدن
الامر بسيط جدا
حيث ان موسكو تقوم بعمليه عسكريه غير
ناجحه في اوكرانيا وهي تعتمد على تكتيكات
ناريه طويله الامد وبالتالي تحصل عليها
بكميه كبيره من ايران اذا ايران شريك
اساسي في الاعتداء على اوكرانيا
بالنسبه لارتباط هذين الملفين في واشنطن
جون هربس يعني ما السبيل بتصورك انت الى
فصل هذين الملفين بالنظر الى ان هناك
مخاوف من تطور عسكري خاصه بين اسرائيل
وايران في الوقت الراهن
كما تعلمون فان اسرائيل التي هي ديمقراطيه
ولا طالما طلبات الدعم باعتبارها
ديمقراطيه لم تقف الى جانب اوكرانيا في
مواجهتها الاعتداء الروسي ولكن الان بمعنى
ايران توفي رولي موسكو هذه الطائرات
المسيره ونتيجه لذلك موسكو مستعد
لتوفير المقاتلين المدربين لايران هذا لفت
طبعا الانتباه اسرائيل وغير حساباتها
ربما تسعى الى دعم ديمقراطيه تشبهها مثل
اوكرانيا بدلا من دعم موسكو اذا ان اعتماد
موسكو على ايران يرغم موسكو على اتخاذ
الخطوات لتوفير التجهيزات العسكريه كما لم
تعهد من قبل
وهذا يدفع اسرائيل الى عده النظر في
موقفها من هذا المنطلق يمكننا القول ان
هذه التطورات تساعد ربما في النهايه
اوكرانيا في تصدي لهذا العدوان الروسي
اذا امكن ان نبدا بمساله الديمقراطيه في
اسرائيل كما تفضل الان السفير جون هربس
يعني هناك
تساؤلات كبيره حاليا في واشنطن عن وضع
الديمقراطيه في اسرائيل بالنظر الى
القلاقله التي تشهدها اسرائيل بين
الاسرائيليين انفسهم وبالنظر الى سياسه
اسرائيل
وما تثيره من تساؤلات ثم هناك التطورات
هذه الزياره التي يقوم بها وزير الدفاع
الامريكي الى منطقه الشرق الاوسط يعني كيف
تنظر روسيا الى هذه الامور فيما يتعلق
بمساله الاستقرار في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
بما قد يخدم المصلحه الروسيه خاصه في ظل
الوضع وضع الحرب في اوكرانيا
تحيه لك ولساده المشاهدين ولضيفتك الكريمه
اعتقد بان روسيا تنظر الى هذه الجوله التي
يقوم بها سيدي
وزير الدفاع الامريكي ربما بقلق نظرا لكون
روسيا والولايات المتحده وكانهما تتسابقان
الان على النفوز سواء في الشرق الاوسط حيث
ان مواقع روسيا اصلا قويه جدا او حتى
بالنسبه لافريقيا لاننا راينا وشاهدنا
الجولات التي قام بها المسؤولين الكبار من
روسيا والولايات المتحده الى القاره
الافريقيه مرارا وتكرارا ولكن بالنسبه
للشرق الاوسط بطبيعه الحال روسيا الان تقف
بحزم ربما اكثر من اي وقت مضى مع الشعب
الفلسطيني وبطبيعه الحال تندد
باعمال اسرائيل الاخيره وربما هي ايضا
شددت نوعا ما من موق المعارض لاسرائيل ليس
فقط
لمعاداتها هي فلسطين والقضيه الفلسطينيه
وانما بسبب الصراع الاوكراني وهنا نحن نرى
ترابطا قويا بين هذين الملفين لانه واضح
تماما ان اسرائيل اذا ربما تخطط او تجاوزت
الخط الاحمر بالنسبه لروسيا
واقدمت على توريد وتزويد اوكرانيا بمختلف
الانواع الاسلحه فلا شك ان روسيا لن تترك
هذا بدون اهتمامها وبطبيعه الحال يكون
الرد الروسيا على مثل هذا التطور المحتمل
قويا عطفا عليه يعني اسرائيل بالنظر الى
ما تفضلت به الان اسرائيل طبعا تحاول ان
تحافظ على علاقات جيده مع روسيا
وايران طبعا لها مصلحه في ان تكون لها
علاقات جيده مع روسيا بل حتى تتهم بان لها
من قبل الامريكيين علاقات عسكريه حاليا مع
الروس يعني كيف يمكن ان او كيف تنظر روسيا
الى افق اندلاع مواجهه عسكريه بين اسرائيل
وايران في ظل هذه التشابات
في ظل هذه التشابات روسيا كذلك تنظر الى
مثل هذا الاحتمال بجديه وهي تاخذ مثل هذا
الاحتمال على محمل الجلد وبلا شك روسيا
سوف تبدي رد فعلها في يتعلق باحتمال ان
اسرائيل او تستهدف مواقع ايرانيه بحجه ان
ايران قريبه جدا مثل الولايات المتحده
مثلا مواقف واشنطن
واسرائيل متقاربه جدا اذا هذا الملف وهناك
قلق مشترك من قبلهما بان ايران قريبه جدا
او اصبحت
علاقهوسين او ادنى من حيازه الاسلحه
النوويه بنتيجه التطورات الاخيره ولكن مع
ذلك افاق من جهه اخرى افاق احياء الاتفاق
النووي تبدو الان الضئيله ولكن بالنسبه
لدول الاتحاد الاوروبي اعتقد بان موقفها
تختلف عنها
الولايات المتحده لان الدول الاوروبيه
ربما تامل وتعول على النفط الايراني الذي
يمكن ان يصبح بديلا للنفط الروسي في ظل
العقوبات المفروضه من قبل الغرب على النفط
وتسقيف اسعار النفط وبالتالي دول
الاوروبيه اعتقد بان لها مصلحه باحياء
الاتفاق النووي بخلاف الولايات المتحده
يعني هل يمكن للولايات المتحده ان تعيد
احياء الاتفاق النووي مع الايرانيين في
نفس الوقت الذي تتهم فيه
واشنطن ايران بانها تزود الروس
بالمسيرات وبانها توثق تعاونها العسكري مع
الروس في اوكرانيا
ليست المساله ان الولايات المتحده ببساطه
تتهم ايران بارسال مسيرات الى روسيا
لاستخدام هذا اوكرانيا فان فعلا ترسل هذه
المسيرات لاستخدامها ضد اوكرانيا وكما
اسلفت فاروسيا تفكر في ارسال طائرات
متقدمه لم تكن لتحسب لها حسابا من قبل اذا
هذه كلها تطورات
حصلت نعرف ان المشكله بين ايران والولايات
المتحده بالنسبه الى موضوع الاتفاق نووي
تعود الى ان انشطه ايران خارج هذا المجال
مثل توفير الاسلحه للارهابيين في الشرق
الاوسط لا تتماشى مع محتوى هذا الاتفاق
وتريده واشنطن من ايران ان تتصرف بطريقه
مسالمه حول مساله انتشار الاسلحه وقضايا
الارهاب الدولي
وان تكون ايران
مستعده للتصرف مسؤوليه حين ذاك فان فرصه
التوصل الى هذا الاتفاق تتعاظم ولكن بدون
ذلك لا ارى حدودا له
لا بل تلاقي روسيا الاسلحه من ايران
للمزيد من الاعتداءات والعدوان في
اوكرانيا هذا ليس مؤشرا الى عمل طهران على
السلام
السفير جوهرز لنفترض فردا ان كل كلمه مما
قلته الان في محلها ودقيقه مئه في المئه
يعني هل يمكن لاداره الرئيس جو بايدن هل
يمكن لاداره الرئيس بايدن ان تتعامل مع
حرب على ابواب اوروبا في المدى القريب
والمتوسط والبعيد وهي اوكرانيا وحرب اخرى
اندلعت في قلب منطقه الشرق الاوسط في
الملف الايراني بالنظر الى التهديدات
الاسرائيليه لايران وبالنظر الى التحركات
الرسميه الامريكيه حاليا في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط
انا ليس لدي ادنى شك
باننا سوف نستمر بتوفير الدعم البارز
لاوكرانيا حتى تدافع عن نفسها ضد اعتداءات
الكريم بالنسبه لاحتمال وقوع حرب في الشرق
الاوسط
ليس لدي ادنى فكره عما اذا كانت ستبدا
الحرب بعد شهر او سته اشهر او سنه في
الشرق الاوسط
ما اعلمه هو انه في حال لو شعره اسرائيل
بان تهديد ايران يتعاظم
فان
اسرائيل سوف تقوم بالتصدي اذا شعرت بان
ايران سوف تقوم بالاعتداء عليها وبالتالي
سوف تعتدي على ايران بطريقه ناجحه انا لا
اتوقع حصول ذلك ولكن اذا حصل لا اعتقد ان
ايران سيكون لديها قدره على الرد
باستثنائي اطلاق بعض الصواريخ التي اعتقد
ان اسرائيل سوف تتمكن من التصدي لها من
خلال نظام القبه الحديديه وقواتها الجويه
وربما من خلال انشطه ارهابيه وسطمكن
اسرائيل ايضا من اداره هكذا ازمه مره اخرى
لا اتوقع ذلك ولا اتوقع حربا وسط النطاق
في الشرق الاوسط
هذا لا اتوقع ذلك ربما ستحصل بعض
الاعتداءات
اذا امكن ان نعود الى الماضي طبعا هناك من
المعلومات والابحاث ما يشير الى ان الرئيس
السابق رئيس الامريكي الاسبقن قد ساهم
بشكل كبير في افلاس الاتحاد السوفياتي من
خلال الحرب الفضاء مثلا يعني هل روسيا
الان بصدد الاجترار الى نفس المصير بحيث
انه الولايات المتحده تدعم اوكرانيا وهناك
عقوبات صارمه ومتعدده مفروضه على روسيا
وبالتالي وكذلك هناك مشكله اخرى في الافق
هي مشكله ايران ان حصلت حرب بين
اسرائيل وايران تضطر روسيا للتدخل
الاستثمار فيها كذلك
انا لا اعتقد ذلك واعتقد بان العباره
الشائعه وهي ان الطريق يعيد نفسه لان لا
ينطبق على
الوضع الان مقارنه مع ما كان عليه ايام
رونال ايام الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق لان
روسيا اولا الان شعبيه الرئيس الروسي
تزايدت كثيرا بالمقارنه مع ما كان عليه
قبل ما يسمى بالبدايه ببدايه العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا هذا اولا
ثانيا روسيا صمدت
وتحملت عباء العقوبات الاقتصاديه التي لم
تؤثر كثيرا على مستوى معيشه المواطن
الروسي رغم طبعا بعض الارتفاعات في
الاسعار وبعض المشاكل الاخرى الا انه بوجه
عام روسيا تمكنت من تحمل كل هذه الصعوبات
مؤشرات ايجابيه حجره بان الناتج الاجمالي
القومي لروسيا سوف يتزايد ولاء بمعدلات
طفيفه في السنه المقبله يعني هذين الامرين
وغيرهما ربما يخلق وتخلق انتبا بان الوضع
في روسيا يختلف تماما عن مكان عليه منذ
سنوات العشيه ما في المثال الذي تفضلت انت
بذكره ايام رونالد تراجن وايام الاتحاد
السوفيتي السابق وبالتالي اعتقد بان روسيا
لن تتاثر بوجه عام لا بالعقوبات ولا
بالمواقف المعادله لها من قبل الدول
الغربيه ولا بمحاولاته اطاله امد الحرب
التي تبذلها الدول الغربيه بامداداتها من
الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا سؤال اخير لك افغاني
سيديروف يعني الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
كانت له علاقه معينه مع الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين كانت له مواقف معينه من
اوكرانيا انما عندما جاء الرئيس بايدن
الرئيس بايدن اصلح جسور الولايات المتحده
مع حلف شمال الاطلسي هناك دول جديده الان
تحاول الانضمام الى حلف شمال الاطلسي
وبالتالي هل شن الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا اتت بنتيجه عكسيه تماما في ظل ما
يقوم به الرئيس جو بايد
انا لا اعتقد ذلك لانه حتى توسيع حلف شمال
الاطلسي حيل في الناتو
بواسطه انضمام مثلا فنلندا والسويد اليها
لن يغير كثيرا من موازين ومن ميزان القوى
لان هذين البلدين فنلندا والسويدا ربما
سوف
يحزوان
بعض البلدان الاسكندريه التي انضمت شكليا
الى حلف الشمال الى اطلانتي ولكنها لم
تسمح بنشر صواريخ وقواعد اجنبيه ومنها
امريكيه على اراضيها وهذا يعني ان روسيا
لن تتاثر
بتوسع حلف الناتو على حساب قبول اعضاء جدد
فيه
للسفير جون هيربس في دقيقه رجاء ماذا عنك
انت هل تعتقد ان سياسه في اوكرانيا
قد اصبحت عكسيه بالنسبه للمصالح الروسيه
في ظل هذه الوحده بين الولايات المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي وحلف الناتو
حربا من الجرائم جرائم الحرف اوكرانيا
ضد الاطفال والنساء وخطف الاطفال
واعتداءات جامعه ضد المدنيين لانه عاجز عن
الفوز على الجيش الاوكراني من خلال جيشه
الان لدينا فنلندا والسويد ومئات الف
الرجال الروس الذين يهدرون روسيا خوفا من
الانضمام الى الجيش ولدينا ايضا هجره
ادمغه لمن يعارض حربا بوتا
واوكرانيا ستفوز بالحرف النهايه شكرا
جزيلا لكل من شكرا جزيلا لكل من السفير
جون هيربست وكذلك لضيفي من موسكو افغاني
سيديروف
تشهد العاصمه الامريكيه هذه الايام نقاشات
معمقه حول الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا وقد
نظمت شبكه القياده عبر الاطلس ندوه في
الاونه الاخيره شارك فيها ساسا ومسؤولون
عسكريون من مختلف البلدان والمنظمات ومن
بينها حلف شمال الاطلسي
وقد تناول النقاش في الندوه العديد من
الملفات كالتنافس الامريكي الصيني والنفوذ
الروسي في العديد من مناطق العالم بما
فيها منطقه الشرق الاوسط طبعا وكذلك الدعم
الامريكي والاوروبي لاوكرانيا في مواجهه
القوات الروسيه اليكسي جونت شارينكو العضو
في البرلمان الاوكراني تحدث الى برنامج من
واشنطن على هامش الندوه
اننا نقاتل هذا امر وجودي بالنسبه لنا ان
نكون او لا نكون نحن ننتصر وقمنا بتحرير
اجزاء من اراضينا ويمكننا ان ننتصر بسرعه
ولكن نحتاج الى سلاح من حلفائنا
اود ان اقدم الشكر على كل الدعم الذي
نتلقاه ولكن الامر ليس سهلا عندما يكون
الدعم كافيا نحقق النصر وحتى الان الدعم
ليس كافيا والامر الاهم بالنسبه لنا هو
الحصول على صواريخ بعيده المدى واسلحه
هجوميه وهذا امر حيوي لنا للانتهاء من هذا
باقصى سرعه لان العالم اجمع سيستفيد من
تحقيقنا نصرا سريعا هاوس
الناس ليس لديهم اي خيار اخر اما يقتلنا
الروس او ننتصر عليهم الراي العام متفائل
والناس متفائلون للغايه بشان مستقبل
البلاد عما كانوا عليه قبل فبراير العام
الماضي الامر لا يصدق لقد تحطمت بلدنا
وقتل الالاف ولكن الناس يشعرون اننا على
المسار
الصحيحتي
استمرينا في العمل حتى عندما كان الجيش
الروسي على بعد 30 كم من مقر البرلمان كان
امرا صعبا وانضم كثير منا الى قوات الدفاع
كنت اذهب الى مقر البرلمان حاملا بندقيه
كلاشنكوف واقف عند مدخل المبنى ثم ادخل
للادلاء بصوتي بعدها اعود لممارسه مهامه
ولكن امكننا ان نستمر والان تحسن الوضع
كثيرا
ازور الولايات المتحده للحصول على دعم
اكثر خاصه الدعم العسكري الاسلحه الهجوميه
طائرات اف 16 ومدرعات اكثر هذا هو ما
نحتاجه
كان ذلك اليكسي جون شارينكو العضو في
البرلمان الاوكراني متحدثا الي على هامشي
ندوه قيا القياده عبر الاطلسي صدر في
الاونه الاخيره كتاب المبعوث اتقان فن
الدبلوماسيه للسفير جوردن الذي اشتهر في
الاوساط الامريكيه باسم رجل الاعمال في
الاوساط الدبلوماسيه كان فعلا رجل اعمال
الى ان عينه الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
سفيرا امريكيا لدى الاتحاد الاوروبي وشغل
ذلك المنصب بين عامي 2018 و20
وكان صندلند احد الشهود في محاكمه دونالد
ترامب برلمانيا في الكونجرس في قضيه
اتهامه بطلب اجراء يخدم مصلحته السياسيه
الشخصيه كرئيس للولايات المتحده من الرئيس
الاوكراني زيلانسكي مقابل تقديم الدعم
للدعم الامريكي لاوكرانيا سالت في البدايه
كيف يسهل كتابه فهم تعامل ترامب او اي
رئيس امريكي اخر مع قضايا السياسه
الخارجيه
ليس المقصود من الكتاب ان يلقي نظره شامله
على رئاسه ترامب والسياسه الخارجيه فحسب
وانما ايضا الدفاع عن امور اخرى تتعارض مع
الفهم الفطري
ما ادافع عنه في الكتاب هو ان يكون هناك
مزيد من التعيينات السياسيه في مناسب
السفراء خلافا لما يبدو انه توجه واشنطن
لان البيروقراطيه لا تريد ان ترى ملء تلك
المناصب بتعينات سياسيه
اما الموضوع الاخر فهو ان الرئيس ترامبا
كان ناجحا فيما اعتبرها دبلوماسيه فعاله
بدلا من دبلوماسيه المظاهر كان الرئيس
ترامب يستخدم الهاتف في التواصل مع
الزعماء تماما كما يفعل رجال الاعمال دوما
من اجل تحريك جداول اعمالنا وما نريد
وبذلك يلغون مشاركه العديد من المسؤولين
الذين تهمهم المشاركه في حد ذاتها اكبر
مما تهمه منتائج
بالنسبه للحرب في اوكرانيا يعني اين ترى
انت اوجه الشبه والاختلاف بين ترامب وبايض
بين تعامل ترامب وتعامل بايدن مع الملف
الاوكراني علما بان الغزو الروسي
لاوكرانيا ايام ترامب لم يكن قد حصل بعد
لا ليس الامر كذلك لانه هناك استمراريه في
العمل الرئاسي من رئيس الى اخر ان
المقارنه الرئيسه هي ان الرئيس بايدن
ولسوء الحظ قد ارسل اشارات خاطئه عن
انسحابنا من افغانستان كما ان بعض
التعليقاته حول غزو الروس لاوكرانيا كانت
بمثابه اشارات الى الرئيس بوتين بانه اذا
كان ينوي غزو اوكرانيا فان الموعد الذي
اختاره لذلك هو الانسب له في تقديره
كان يتعامل مع رئيس امريكي وما علاقه
امريكيه اوروبيه مشروخه تعطيه نوعا من
الفرصه لاني اعتقد وكما يقولون في مجال
التكنولوجيا ان بوتين كان في عمقه مبرمجا
لغزو اوكرانيا انه كان يريد دوما غزو
اوكرانيا وكان السؤال فقط متى يقوم بذلك
احترام فكان يعتقد ان هذا الاخير لم يكن
من السهل توقع ردوده وكان يخيف خصومه يعني
انما قد يقال سفير ان طريقه في التعامل مع
اوكرانيا قد اساءت الى المصالح الامريكيه
بالنظر الى التهم التي كما تعرف كانت قد
وجهت الى
واجريت له محاكمه
بسببها في الكونجرس رغم انه لم تتم ادانته
في نهايه المطاف
لم يتعامل ترامب مع قضيه اوكرانيا من
منطلق شروطه بالنسبه لرغبته في عقد اجتماع
مع زيلنسكي وهو ما كنا انا وزملائي نوصي
به ترامب وشعرنا بالاحباط لانه لم يقم
بذلك دون شروط ومن ثم فان المكالمه
الهاتفيه التي ادت في النهايه الى الصخب
في الكون حيث حكم برلمانيا لم يتم التعامل
معها بسهوله ويسر
ان مكالمات كهذه تحدث دوما بين الزعماء
ولا اعتقد ان اوباما او بايدن او بوش يمكن
ان يقولوا بصدق انهم لم يجروا مكالمات
كهذه الفرق هو انه لم يكن حولهم من يبلغ
عنهم كما حصل مع ترامب
الانسحاب من افغانستان معهد الطريقه لغزو
اوكرانيا فعندما كانت ترامب في الرئاسه
وانا لا اؤيد اعاده انتخابه نظرا لما جرى
في السادس من يناير كانون الثاني وجدت انه
اخطا في تعامله مع موضوع اوكرانيا لكن
اعتقد ان اتصالاته بروسيا ومع الحكومه
الافغانيه كانت صارمه ولم يكون ليلحق اي
ضرر باي من رعايانا ايام رئاسته
يعني
بالنظر الى
ما يقول الاوكرانيون انهم قد حققوه في عام
الحرب ضد القوات الروسيه يعني ما الذي
تعتقد انت السفير ان على اداره بايدن ان
تقبل به او الا تقبل به لانهاء الحرب في
اوكرانيا
اعتقد ان هذا عائد الى الاوكرانيين وهم
وحدهم يقررون متى يريدون التفاوض ولهم
رئيسهم هو زلانسكي لا اعتقد ان على اداره
بايدن او الاتحاد الاوروبي اي يملي على ما
يجب عليه القيام به هناك خياران ثنائيان
وهو الدعم العسكري المستمر والمساعدات
الانسانيه وليس المساعدات العسكريه فقط
للحفاظ على اوضاع قائمه او كي يحقق
الاوكرانيون خطوه او خطوتين الى الامامه
ثم يتراجعون بما يكبدهم خساره في الارواح
والبنيه التحتيه اقول ان الخيارين هما هل
نريد لهم الانتصار ام لا فاذا كنا نريده
من ينتصروا فاننا نعلم كيف نساعدهم في ذلك
ولم يتم اتخاذ قرار كهذا حتى هذا الوقت في
الحرب وهو ما يؤسف له
نهايه السيد السفير يعني بالنظر الى انك
كنت سفير للرئيس دونلد ترامب يعني بالنسبه
لجو باين الى اي مدى تعتقد انه قد احسن
صنعا
بتحسينه لعلاقات الولايات المتحده مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي
وكذلك بتحسين موقعه داخل منظومه حلف شمال
الاطلسي خاصه فيما يتعلق بملف اوكرانيا
نعم اعتقد ذلك اعتقد ان الرئيس بعيدا قد
قام بعمل جيد في جمع الاتحاد الاوروبي في
الدفاع عن اوكرانيا ما اخذ عليه هو تردد
ادارته وخشيتها من التصعيد الروسيه الذي
حصل على ايه حال وعلى مستوى كبير رغم انه
لم يصل الى المستوى النووي ويجب ان نسمي
الامور باسمائها وان نعمل على مساعده
الاوكرانيين على الانتصار باعطاء اسلحه
بعيده المدى وتغطيه جويه وبتغيير الطائرات
الروسيه العتيقه لديهم واستبدالها بطائرات
اف 16 او طائرات من نوع اخر نتوفر على عدد
كبير منه نحن وحلفاؤنا ذروية
الولايات المتحده السابق لدى الاتحاد
الاوروبي واحد الشهود في محاكمه الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب في الكونجرس انتهت
الحلقه يمكنكم التواصل معنا كالمعتاد عبر
بريدنا الالكتروني وفيسبوك وتويتر شكرا
لكم جميعا الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]